races on now to find survivors in the
Bahamas after Hurricane durian flattened
some of the islands the monster storm
battered the area for 48 hours and many
people are unaccounted for Niki batiste
is in the Bahamian capital of Nassau at
Princess Margaret Hospital Nikki what's
the situation there where you are good
morning Tony what there are 35 patients
who were injured in the storm and then
rescued now being treated here but there
are still thousands of people missing on
the islands I spoke with one patient who
says he was separated from his young son
when the hurricane hit their home on
Abaco island
Adrienne Farrington senior says he broke
his leg while trying to save his young
son AJ's life he thought he was keeping
his five-year-old son safe by holding
him on a roof away from floodwaters
Richard Johnson is AJ's older brother
he's trying to find him how hopeful are
you that Adrienne still alive given the
circumstances I'm not that hopeful the
way I can rely on a lot above the rest
assure that's that's going to be hopeful
from there Adrienne a carpenter says he
was rescued by civilians and brought to
Princess Margaret Hospital in Nassau on
Monday he said while he was fighting for
his life he saw at least 12 others drown
crying 40 lives in my head
I still can see my son getting dragged
across the roof reaching up Richard
brought this flyer with photos of AJ to
the National Emergency Management Agency
the still looking around in terms of
shelters there's a possibility you might
be in a shelter his family hopes to be
as lucky as some others but Adrienne
fears the worst to see them when another
disaster Adrienne Farrington says he
just wants to hear that his son is alive
they had to break the news to AJ's
mother that he is missing and as you can
imagine she was extremely emotional
Adrienne says AJ was wearing a blue
hoodie and blue sneakers when he slipped
out of his hands Tony Miki booties for
us in the Bahamas where the human toll
continues to rise Niki thank you very
much and we'll have more coverage of
hurricane durian ahead as we start to
take power hits here in Charleston South
Carolina in the meantime let's go back
to studio 57 in New York Tony thank you
you know just to hear those stories I
think people are in such shock right now
there's no doubt and just heartbreaking
can't imagine it's the second story
we've heard in two days of somebody
slipping out of the hands of a loved one
it's just it's it's really painful
yeah prayers with that family